the Joe Rogan experience cuz people are
so into it come on board diet is a lot
like the vegan diets they can't shut the
[ __ ] up about being a carnivore
my buddy Michael Goldstein who is the
first person I know who's about Bitcoin
isn't that Bitcoin Bitcoin Bitcoin same
thing with carnival carnival carnival
carnival right so I tried it for a
couple of weeks I think I went from like
close to two weeks and after a while I
was like Jesus Christ or twenty regular
foods I I'm not being I'm not joking I
would think you'll be a problem with
getting it stuck in your teeth all the
time no you just brush your teeth what
are you dusting what's wrong with you
have a toothpick at home excuse me I
have every flavor of Marvis on my shelf
right now Marvis Oh interesting now who
doesn't know about tooth care what's
Marvis is the like italian toothpaste
brand it looks really cool although the
flavors are so far the point is brushing
your teeths not gonna get it not stuck
in between your teeth that's not gonna
help flossing yeah flaw you're gonna be
out flossing all the time no or just
bite off bigger chunks like a man just
swallow it
okay I'll always chew can I tell you a
story about this this just happened to
me yes and this is when I realized that
most people there's no mind there I am
at a buffet I'm eating steak I was
eating steak congratulations
I get stuck in my throat I'm like all
right it's just too big a piece I'll
just wash it down mmm it's not going
anywhere and I realized I'm choking and
it was a very scary situation in the
sense that mentally I knew there is a
percent chance that I'm gonna die did
you try to throw up hold on hold on I'll
let me tell the story Joe Rogan so I'm
sitting there I'm like holy [ __ ] I'm
choking and I'm like alright I was calm
but I'm like your life is currently in
danger and there's a three people at the
next table two got two in there two
women their 50s I got in their 60s I go
up to them and I'm like I know what to
do because I was at school and I go them
and I go I'm choking and I did the hand
motion and I make eye contact with each
of them no look no effect on their face
and I'm like at the very least you have
a crazy person
coming up to your table doing a neck
motion were you in New York yeah that's
a problem I people do sense diets did
this to myself and it shot out
and then I go to how to do yourself show
me her I just did this that so and I saw
Heimlich like I don't know if it was the
cloth or whatever it popped out and all
the liquid to after it and I go to them
I go I was just choking and they're like
oh well you should shoot your food
better I'm like someone was just shocked
said that's you the old one the ladies
should get that lady's name she doesn't
have an answer because there's not a
human being there
there's no mind and I'm like holy [ __ ]
if I saw this happen and I didn't help I
would be like oh my god you just oh my
holy [ __ ] are you okay
it was like I should shoot your food
you're not a soul holds this hair 50s
somebody probably just treat her bad man
not bad enough bad relationships it was
scary
the reaction was scarier than the
choking yeah I would imagine well I
think that's a really common thing with
big cities that that sort of there's a
diffusion of responsibility there's so
many people there's so many you don't
feel responsible for this guy with his
hands on his neck saying I'm coughing
like somebody else go take somebody
handle this I work I would be fine if
they had shrugged and then like yeah
whatever in a sense but there was no
reaction she's probably so jaded so
whoever you are lady
I hope exactly you [ __ ] you I I hope you
go back in time and you have a better
daddy and a better mommy and better
friends yeah then you grow up to be a
nice person and I and yeah in her 50s
maybe she could be a yogi she's gonna
save someone's life in her mind and be
like I saved someone's life today I go
into heaven yeah maybe she thought you
were nuts and you're just trolling her
but if I was nuts you would think they'd
pull back and be like holy [ __ ] there's
a crazy person in our table maybe it's
because of your troll like wait the
universe is sent your way you're the boy
who cried wolf
the lesson is you're invincible and
nothing bad will ever happen oh because
you survived I survived Oh